the jobs are there but the manpower is
missing faced with increasingly urgent
labor shortages Germany's casting its
nets far afield in the search for
skilled workers policymakers are
actively courting workers for sectors
from health care to food services
Health Minister spun traveled to Mexico
on his quest a new law aims to promote
skilled labor immigration at the same
time Germany's deporting refugees whose
temporary asylum has expired and
xenophobic right-wing parties are on the
rise open or closed is Germany a country
of immigration that's our topic on to
the point
welcome and thanks for joining us here
on to the point where our guests in the
studio are mottle aiming who is an
opinion writer for the Berlin Daily the
tango Spiegel he says Germany is in a
global competition for qualified
immigrants to be successful it must
offer greater incentives and better
conditions and it's a pleasure to
welcome Zappa Gino Chuck he is a
freelance author and journalist born in
Ankara and resident in Germany since
1970 he says unified Germany still has
no immigration policy based on reality
but is under enormous pressure to act
and great to have with us Anna Alvarez
she is originally from Costa Rica and
now works with the berlin-based
migration hub network which provides
support to international projects
working with migrants she says it seems
like we're going back to well-known
regulations for getting the real
contribution the current and future
migrants make to this country so let me
begin by asking all of you this I have
been in Germany myself for 35 years now
and for as long as I can remember this
country has been engaging in passionate
debate with itself about precisely this
question whether it is a country of
immigration
what makes this discourse so tortured
I'm not quite sure whether it's it's a
real German phenomenon or specific to
Germany I mean if you look around all
industrialized nations from the backers
and Donald Trump and the the brexit
discussion and Great Britain Scandinavia
France Austria all these countries they
all struggle with the relationship
between native-born population and
migrants and refugees so so there is
something that I mean Germans like to
argue and to discuss their own identity
questions a lot but it's not exclusively
Germany that does it and I agree to some
extent because somehow as a migrant
myself in Germany it feels like
Germany's still trying to identify what
kind of migrants they want in this
country undeniably Germany is a
migration country and you know denying
that would be the ninth main
a lot of migrants who have made an
incredible contribution to this country
so far you've been here in Germany even
longer than I have do you have a similar
impression that this debate just goes on
and on in new iterations absolutely I
think it brings a lot of tension but
maybe it's also profit for a lot of
people to discuss this and not to finish
I don't know but in the end without a
joke I think it's a serious problem
because we have kind of amnesia in this
question the basic the background of
this discussion is in fact the guest
worker the death culture of the 60s of
the 70s and the German society didn't
develop a real positive constructive
attitude toward towards the experience
of work migration the migrants have a
enormous positive memory of this time so
there's a gap between this negative
attitude among a lot of Germans people
don't integrate very safe foreign they
don't communicate and so on and the
other ones who say we could come to this
country and could find a safe place we
could make our living here we could
invest in our home countries and we
could really bring our children's world
here and this is the way we have to
bring this together more together to
have a more realistic view of future
immigration thank you let us just give a
listen to how a few Germans with a
migration background actually also
answered this question about whether
Germany has become a country of
immigration Deutsche Welle launched an
ambitious social media survey to find
out what they think here's a sample is
Right today Germany is a multicultural
country it already is a society based on
immigration
that's not something for the distant
future it's already reality playfully
mommies in Dutch so maybe some people
just don't want to believe that we're
already such a diverse society
those of you felt isn't a limit miss of
cool in my opinion someone who would
describe me as not German just because
of my name or something else doesn't
understand Germany time for touch this
is my name I don't know Dutch we are a
nation of immigrants Otsu insolent so
over this long debate during at least
some of its phases the word
multicultural Malta has not necessarily
had positive connotations for a lot of
people here in Germany yet the first
speaker that we heard used it in a very
positive way as a statement of fact what
do you think I think it should be used
in a positive way I mean you have to
differentiate between the simple fact
that Germany is the diversity of
multicultural immigration country I mean
there's simply effect because people
from migrant backgrounds now I may be in
the near future will be 25% of the
population who can deny that it is a
migrant country the the next thing is to
have a positive attitude towards being
that to value the contribution migrants
have to for the country starting with
the recruitment agreements in the 50s
and 60s with Italy Spain Greece and all
these countries but ending now with the
immigration off we saw we had the
example of young span the the Minister
of Health who's travelling around the
world to get migrants coming to Germany
we're going to see another example of
that a little bit later on but let me
ask you this Anna
one person's multi-culti is another
person's parallel society the idea that
different ethnic groups live next to
each other essentially in a form of
ghetto caught cut off from the larger
society what's your experience as a
person who's been in this country now
for I think it's four years it's only
four years but I work with migrants wolf
being here ready for you know more years
and that and and I have seen with them
what's the was a transition that takes
to actually feel integrated and there's
many people sadly who even have born
here and they
don't even feel themselves German so
there is definitely I would like to
highlight what Malthus said I mean we
have to work towards look at it that's a
positive thing because unfortunately
still in in the streets and in the
society many people tend to get their
eyes their culture or their aDNA see
because there is not that openness in
you know in the real life or in the
daily life for them to express their
culture the religions so of course they
feel more safe towards together eyes and
enjoying their groups then rather just
you know integrate with with the rest of
the society I would stress that parallel
societies a part of an integration
society because not only because they
they are not being welcomed by open arms
but because they tend to be - towards
each other be they speak their own
language they try to help each other -
so they they have a block in communities
we have Little Italy in New York we have
China towns everywhere so these are
parallel societies but that doesn't
exclude integration they are more
accepting I think this person in Germany
but the question during question is why
we are panicking so much why there is a
much panic and hysteria and discussion
for example I experienced two different
immigration processes one was coming
from Turkey - to Munich in the beginning
of 70s as a child and the second was is
growing up man coming from Munich to
Berlin real culture shock yes
so people live different they have
different ideas of their lives and this
is part of modern open touristy
societies we have to insure people that
they can lead you live a life
differently without having this big
topics always perilous society because
what is parallel society in Berlin in
the high middle class areas life is also
very very parallel if you compare it to
two places in Berlin where more social
conflicts are so it's a it's nothing
it's a the the point of fear coming out
from different
this is the main issue can I ask you for
another comparison you talk about open
pluralistic societies one country that
is often seen that way is Canada Canada
has quotas for skilled labour
immigration but it also tends to take
quite a large number of refugees I know
that you lived and worked in Canada so
can you give us a nutshell comparison of
that society compared with this one I
think the attitude I was by the way more
in the United States been in Canada but
I have some experience was in Canada and
the attitude is the more important thing
I don't expect in fact Germany becoming
Canada this is not realistic this is a
country says that traditions is a
history we have to talk about it the
problem is that we don't talk really
about it you know we talk always about
immigration immigration against
immigration no shut the closet borders
open the borders it's not not that easy
we have to push away the amnesia and to
look in our history which is a difficult
history in the 20th century by the way
and to the story after the war and we
have to see what is German today how it
can change and how fix it is it Malta
there's another layer to that history as
well namely 2015 when we had hundreds of
thousands of refugees entering this
country many of them from Syria many of
them fleeing the war there was quite a
shift in attitudes Zafar says it's all
about attitudes there was quite a shift
in attitudes what was initially heralded
as a welcomed culture turned bitter why
what happened but these are two
different discourses the discourse about
the refugees into 2015 and 2016 is is
basically driven by humanitarian
arguments being tolerant being in open
society and so on and so on
the migration discussion is around
competition is about seeing the fact
that three-quarters of migrants go to -
- just four countries the United States
Great Britain Canada and Australia why
because they're english-speaking
countries they have an excellent school
and at university system and so on you
have to be attractive
for migrants in the future - - to have a
stay in the in the global competition I
mean Germany ranks in attractiveness and
ranked 12th in the 3000 countries which
are developed this is not enough so
Germans have to have to have to
recognize the fact there is not just the
question of being tolerant open and
welcoming but the necessity of having
more immigrants this is something
because the image of Germany is very
positive by a lot of countries and this
ranking is very interesting there is a
gap between this rank and the per image
and I think that has to do with the self
image of the Germans that they they have
difficulties to accept that they are
loved somewhere else
yes and basically I wouldn't separate
that topic the migration were the ones
who whoever eyes in 2015 I mean let's
look at how are they doing these days I
try there's a report right it says that
forty four hundred thousand have got a
job what kind of jobs does another story
but I work with many of them and
actually the attitude that many of them
have taken towards integrating into I
mean following the rules so to say it's
been phenomenon they go to German
classes they're working aside I mean
they're really trying let me let me stop
you right there because we actually have
a report about exactly such a young man
and let it be said that it is perhaps
not confusing that Germans often confuse
this debate because for many for a long
long time they had no category for
skilled labor immigration it was only
refugees those who came in 2015 were
looking for refugee status let's take a
look at a young man who is one of those
who has received a temporary refugee
recognition but who lives in uncertainty
not knowing when he might be sent home
it's the danger to him in his home
country recedes we visited a young man
from Afghanistan
case has had a stable job at the
migration office and I position for
little under a year now he came to
Germany five years ago and speaks German
well that makes him a prime example of
successful integration back in
Afghanistan he had been in the military
but he fled the country after receiving
serious threats case loves his new home
but his residency status makes him worry
his right to stay is only temporary so
each year he has to reapply for
extensions for his wife and two children
what happens when one year is up what
will happen to my children and my family
we can't go back to Afghanistan I left
everything behind to build a new future
I wanted to live in safety but
nevertheless we haven't truly arrived we
can only wait should Germany be more
open towards well integrated immigrants
let me pass that question right on to
you Anna because you were saying we
shouldn't make this distinction between
essentially the skilled on the one hand
to contribute to the economy and the
others who are often seen as a drag on
the economy so what about a young man
like Geist he's a contribution to this
economy he's a contribution to this
country as many that has arrived in the
recent years actually parallel to DS new
act right that enters in March first
there was another act that also passed
the Act to allow skilled labor
immigration to sectors like health care
exactly and there's another one that
passed exactly at the same time it
actually entered into force I guess in
February or something like that which is
the temporary suspension of deportation
because many of like them cases like
that existed in Germany where they
already got a job but they were in the
process of weather protection or they
were not you know into a refugee status
zone so now this act also is gonna
protect people like them right so I
think that's I want to highlight what
you said I mean what are we panicking
about I mean perhaps it's very important
that we don't make a distinction and
then we see everybody as a contribution
and I also have many examples
like like the one that you just showed
actually from Syrian refugees as well
many of them especially the ones who had
a doctor background which is basically
one of the skill sets that it's looked
or its interest in this new Act and
they're already working and they're
ready as doctors and they're the ones
who are saying Germany needs more
migrants or more people who works in the
for example health what of difficulties
they have connected to the issue that
there was a kind of impression that
state lost state and officials lost
control on this issue they had this
experience 2015 hundreds of thousands
this was in the end it was right there
was a control and and the the the next
thing goes that it was enormous misused
by right-wing politicians and by people
or organize the panic you know and there
is a kind of sense sensitivity in this
issue
because there is the story that are
enormous amounts of people who wants to
come to Europe and especially to Germany
and if you don't care about this it will
be overrun so this is this is a this is
a talk we cannot just shut our eyes we
have to open our eyes and we have to
look in it and we have to address it we
have to communicate issue what is the
rational way how immigration could be
organized and I think this example that
you're just show to us yeah demonstrates
this in a perfect way because we have on
the one hand a moral obligation to
protect these people because they helped
the German army in Afghanistan they are
seen by locals as collaborators so we
have a moral obligation to help them on
the other hand german taxpayers invested
in these people for education giving
language courses housing them for health
care and so on and so on i don't know
how much money in each person of them
but to expel them after a certain time
mean we invest it and just waste the
money so that just an economical reason
just stupid to do that master can I just
ask you because Zafar has basically
implied that right-wing politicians are
instrumentalizing
xenophobia precisely in regard to
young refugees like Kyi's would you say
that's true and by the way that they
handle this our mainstream politicians
running scared in front of the this
right-wing fervor
I think they instrumentalized that but I
think that is again that is a European
if not a worldwide phenomenon I mean in
the moment you have in a couple of
months hundred thousands of people
coming in uncontrolled and you have a
right-wing populist party by ten percent
I think that's what could have been
expected I don't want to excuse that or
to to minimize the political impact but
I think there is a correlation between
the acceptance of migration and the
feeling that is in in a way controlled
migration and on an uncontrolled
migration now it's really important what
you're saying as a but let's not forget
there is a new report from the cafe
which is this German Bank estate that
says that in the East and in the rural
areas in Germany forty percent of the
people are against or they said that
they don't need skilled label migrants
because of course and this is what
that's the target of their other
right-wing these population because they
are afraid they are they have they are
unemployed right they people they belong
part of the three point one percent of
the people who are unemployed in this
country so of course their fear is that
increases and that's what also Germany
should look at into more precisely and
more thoroughly also how we can
integrate the ones who are in unemployed
in the moment let me just I'm gonna stop
you here because our time is limited and
I do want to take at least a brief look
at the other side of the coin at the
same time that Germany is wrestling with
right-wing xenophobia it's also actively
seeking skilled labor abroad a new law
and a public relations campaign are
designed to attract promising candidates
these 16 women from Namibia are learning
German with music they're trained nurses
but because they have no chance of
finding work in their home country
they're applying for jobs in Germany
employees at the University Hospital in
Dusseldorf travelled to Namibia
especially for job interviews I feel
it's a good opportunity for my personal
development and
my career as well and for my for the
things I want to do in the future
to explore a bit and to work in
world-class health facility and gain
more professional experience the Yalu
hopes to soon be able to support her
family in Namibia with the income she
earns here later she hopes to study in
Germany or shall return to Namibia after
the interviews in wind Hook the team
from Dusseldorf is excited to tell you
our clinic has decided that we would
like to have all of them in Dusseldorf
but is everyone profiting from the
migration of skilled workers to Germany
exactly the question that einige
Australis let me ask you this is that
for five month language course and then
off to Germany so question would be how
well-prepared are these young women
likely to be for what awaits them here
and what will become of them later do
you think this country will do better at
integrating them then it has many other
I also think that this country
integrated a lot of caseworkers very
very well in the end this is a question
of psychological discourse if you want
because if you see all the bad sides of
immigration you can have a picture if
you see only the good sides you can have
a picture the dude ranches in the middle
I mean you have you have it's great you
know you have this dark sites and good
sites and you have problems in this
society important is how you'll solve
the problems and how you can advise
people to act more realistic and and
relaxed in the same way I mean they have
an enormous efficient organization of
life here in this country
and we are able to to integrate a lot of
people this is without the question but
at the same time we have an almost fears
in a part of the society not a small
part I don't think it's a majority but
it is 30 40 percent of people are mostly
negative towards immigration because of
all of enormous many many many
and we have to address the reasons it's
very important if you don't address the
reasons you will have more and more
problems but is this an either-or should
Germany stop looking to namibia for
skilled workers and simply invest more
in education and training for people
like Cayuse the young afghan man it's
basically a question of sensitivity I
mean if he if a Minister of Health gives
the impression that a rich white man
from a European country comes with a
pocket full of money to buy Labour's to
Germany I think that would be a very
very dangerous impression you have to
see in some in some cases you you cause
even a brain drain in developing
countries this is compensated in most
cases due to the fact of their
remittance these people pay to their
families in their own countries but you
have to I mean you have to talk about
all these and and and in looking for
skilled workers is one thing but but
qualifying your own if it's refugees or
migrants in your own country is the next
thing that is at least as important as
the first thing so Anna last last
question goes to you and we go back to
our title multi says we need to talk
about it is the talk achieving something
would you say Germany is evolving toward
a country of immigration open rather
than closed mmm I don't know how this
public relationship campaign will go I'm
actually looking forward to see that
aftermath March first but the impression
right now towards the migrants that I
here is what what about us
yes Germany has done an impressive work
but still there's so many things that
needs to be fixed internally even for
the ones to come I mean I am part of a
country for example that I cannot open a
bank account easily in Germany so it's
very important that these little minor
details that really counts a lot into
the integration are fixed first and
secondly let's also take into a look
into the ones that are here already what
are the skill sets many of them it is
particularly the ones who came into a
new 15 they are going in through our
building processes right so they will be
highly skilled in a very
in a very short period of time and they
will be also part of these skill level
migrants so that's the question that we
will see as I guess is that the ban says
this this Act last question one-word
answer please when people from your
country and from Latin American
generally look at Germany what do they
see open or closed it's open and
aspirational but not necessarily that
reality when they come here thank you
very much to have you for being with us
today and thanks to you out there for
tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]